OVERTIME A COUPLE NIGHTS AGO. SR
END ARE JUST MISSES THE POST. R
GOING TO THE  L.E, DOWN LOW, ON
NET, LINE.
THEY FREE THE PUCK
FOR CHECKING, CREATING
TURNOVERS, WINNING TATHEM TO FI
OUT, SO FAR THEY'VE HAD A
COUPLE OF GOOD SHIFTS.  GREGOR,
MADE BY PETERSEN MAYBE A PLAY A
EACH OF THE SEASON AGAINST THE
NUMBER 2 PENALTY KILL AND
HERTL.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ARE ON THE
KILL AND YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO  EITHER AGAINST F
WAS ABLE TO GET THE STICK ON
THAT POCKET WATCH FOR THE
REBOUND GOES RIGHT OFF THE
POCKET PICKED. NT UP,
SHOT GOES OFF
ZONE TIME TOLD THE STORY SHOT
ATTEMPTS TO TELL A STORY NOW
LET'S SEE IF  TOPOWER PLAY
CERTAINLY SEEMS SO FOR ANDRE RET
ABLE TO FIND THE PUCK BECAUSE
THE DEFENDER IS TRE POST.
THE LIGHT WENT ON BEHIND NOT  J
GET THIS PUCK TO THE NET AND OF
THE NET SO CLOSE TO ENDING UP
BEHIND HIM. THAT NEW
SIGNED EXTENSIONTHE NUMBERS FRO
SAP COACHING INSIGHTS APP.
>>Bob: HERTL
THAT PUCK.
SLASH ON LEAD.
>>Brian: MAKE SURE YOU DON'T
GIVE UP ANY RUSH CHANCES.
>>Bob:
MINUTES.
L.A..
FINDS AWAY TO COME UP
KEMPE, SO GOOD ALL YEAR LONG
HIT A DRY SPOT IN